[Música]
hoy en directo vamos a quito allí se
encuentra gustavo ortega corresponsal de
france 24 con quien vamos a conversar
sobre la situación del ex presidente
ecuatoriano rafael correa que en 2020
fue condenado a 8 años de prisión y huyó
a bélgica ahora la corte nacional de
justicia lo pidió en extradición pero
bruselas le otorgó el asilo político
gustavo cuéntenos más de lo que se vive
en ecuador en torno a este tema
si cubres noche tales como tú le has
indicado el presidente de la corte
nacional de justicia iván aquí se la
informó que ha afirmado la providencia
este es un documento para iniciar así el
periodo de extradición al el reino de
bélgica pero él sustentaba este pedido
de extradición en cuanto a un acuerdo de
extradición que existe entre ecuador y
bélgica que data de 1887 de igual forma
también en cuanto a un convenio
anticorrupción que tiene ecuador con las
naciones unidas- de igual una ley
vigente de extradición básicamente lo
que solicita el gobierno ecuatoriano a
través del presidente de la corte
nacional de justicia es que el
presidente rafael correa sea extraditado
a ecuador para que concluya o cumple su
condena de ocho años de prisión
recordemos que en el año 2020 como tú lo
habías indicado el ex presidente rafael
correa fue sentenciado junto a otros 20
funcionarios a altos cargos y
empresarios por el delito de cohecho
pero en el año 2017 el ex presidente
rafael correa reside en bélgica por el
cual se ha comenzado este pedido de
extradición y cuáles han sido las
reacciones una vez que se le ha
concedido el asilo político y que
argumenta el ejecutivo nacional
pero las principales reacciones que ha
producido esta solicitud ha sido de
total sorpresa básicamente porque el
ejecutivo nacional tanto la corte
nacional de justicia como la cancillería
y el ministerio de interior ha recibido
esta decisión del reino de bélgica con
total sorpresa específicamente en la
corte nacional de justicia ha dicho que
no tenía conocimiento de este cambio del
estatus básicamente ha sido una
información emitida por parte del
gobierno de del comisariado de
refugiados de bélgica sé que habría sido
confirmada por su abogado y este así ha
sido confirmado por su ex abogado en el
país de que rafael correa ha recibido
este cambio de estatus como refugiado
político básicamente ha sido una
información el comisariado de refugiado
ha dicho que no se pronunciaría al
respecto ha sido una información que ha
tomado por sorpresa inclusive al
ejecutivo nacional pero a pesar de ello
ellos continuarán con el pedido de
extradición pero básicamente los
especialistas en derecho internacional
ha dicho que él otorgar el asilo
político al ex presidente rafael correa
entorpece mucho este pedido de
extradición y muy posible el gobierno
contra reciba una respuesta negativa a
la solicitud de extradición